اي سفينه اسرائيليه ستمر من باب المندب
ستكون فريسه سهله امام نيراننا هكذا
اعلنها الحوثيون جيش من المحامين من انحاء
العالم يلاحقون الكيان وخلافات حاده في
الداخل الامريكي بشان حرب القطاع وتل ابيب
تهدد مصر وتعلن تجاهل الراي العالمي
الولايات المتحده تلجا للصين لحل مشكلتها
النيتو يقترح على كييف التفاوض باستخدام
حيله قديمه المره الثانيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتراجع عن دعم اوكرانيا الدفاع
الاوكرانيه تحدد اسباب الضربه الروسيه
الساحقه لاحد اليتها زيلنسكي يواجه
انتقادات لاذعه وقوات كيف تغير تكتيكها
القتالي البحر الاحمر
يشتعل الحرب مشكله لجيرانها لكن في
الحقيقه فلا احد يتضرر
كاطراد المتحدث باسم الجيش العبري بيتر
ليرنر بنزوح نحو مليون شخص او اكثر من
شمال القطاع الى جنوبه فيما اعتبر وزير
الماليه العبري بيتسلي ايس متريش ان
الهجره الطوعيه واستيعاب سكان القطاع في
دول العالم هو حل انساني ينهي معاناه
اليهودي والعرب على حد سواء من جهته قال
لا اوربن دور المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
العبريه ان بلاده تعطي الراي العام
العالمي بشان الحرب هذه المره اهتماما اقل
من المرات السابقه في المواقف الدوليه دعت
هيومان رايتس وتش الى التحقيق في القصف
العبري لمستشفيات القطاع فيما صرح محامي
حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم في تركيا متن
كونوك عبر منصه اكس ان انقره رفعت دعو
قضائيه ضد نتنياهو امام المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بسبب الانتهاكات للقانون الانساني
الدولي في القطاع من جهتها دعت الحكومه
البريطانيه تل ابيب الى احترام حرمه
المستشفيات في القطاع ومنح المدنيين
الحمايه التي يقرها الق الانون الدولي هذا
وتطوع 300 محام من مختلف الجنسيات
والاديان من كافه انحاء العالم لمحاكمه
تلبيب على جرائمها بحق القطاع وبادر محام
فرنسي يدعم مايت جلدي فيغ الى حشد جيش من
المحامين خلال عشره ايام ليخرج المستشار
الالماني اولاف شولتز مصرحا بان تلابيب
ديمقراطيه وملتزمه بحقوق الانسان والقانون
الدولي وان اللومه الموجهه ضدها سخيفه في
ظل رار الحرب على القطاع لياتي الرد على
شولتس من اليمن حيث اعلنت القوات المسلحه
التابعه للحوثيين انهاها اطلقت دفعه من
الصواريخ البالستيه على اهداف مختلفه
للجيش العبري منها اهداف حساسه في منطقه
ام الرشراش ايلات واضافت القوات اليمنيه
في بيانها ان اطلاق الصواريخ البالستيه
اتى بعد 24 ساعه فقط من عمليه عسكريه اخرى
نفذتها بالطائرات المسيره على الاهداف
العبريه ذاتها مؤكده البدا في اتخاذ كافه
الاجراءات العمليه لتنفيذ التوجيهات
الصادره بشان التعامل المناسب مع اي سفينه
عبريه في البحر الاحمر واضاف البيان لن
نتردد في استهداف اي سفينه عبريه في البحر
الاحمر او اي مكان تطاله ايدينا ابتداء من
لحظه اعلان هذا البيان في امريكا افادت
شبكه سي ان ان بان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
اعترف بوجود خلافات بشان التعا مع حرب
القطاع واكد ان على واشنطن القيام بالمزيد
للتخفيف من معاناه المدنيين هناك ياتي ذلك
بعد توقيع 100 موظف في الخارجيه الامريكيه
على مذكره تنتقد نهج واشنطن تجاه الحرب
اما بشان مصر فذكر تقرير صادر عن مجله
اسرائيل ديفنس التي تصدر عن الجيش العبري
ان تلابيب مطالبه بتهديد مصر واذا لزم
الامر ايضا فعل تلبيب الهجوم على جميع
الجبهات اليكم
[موسيقى]
المصدر بالعوده الى واشنطن ذكرت وكاله
بلومبرج ان القمه المرتقبه بين الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ونظيره الصيني شيجين
بينغ قد تسفر عن اتفاق للحد من تدفق
الفنتانيل للقاتل على الولايات المتحده
وافادت الوكاله نقلا عن وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه قولها ان بكين على اعداد لتنفيذ
اجراءات مكافحه تهريب المخدرات مع
الولايات المتحده على اساس المساواه
والاحترام
المتبادل طعنه الحلفاء ضربات الحلفاء
تتوالى على كيب هنا مستشار قياده القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه يوري اجنا ينفي بدا
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على مقاتلات
اف 16 في رومانيا فيما صرح وزير الدفاع
الالماني بوريس بيستوريوس بان هدف الاتحاد
الاوروبي المعلن سابقا بتزويد اوكرانيا
بمليون قذيفه في المستقبل القريب بعيد
المنال هنا ضربه اخرى ولكن بيد الجيش
الروسي وبعد ان قتل العديد من ضباط القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه رفيعي المستوى في
الجزء الذي تسيطر عليه كيب من مقاطعه زبرو
جا وذلك بضربه صاروخيه شنتها القوات
المسلحه الروسيه صرح وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني روستم عمروف ان ذلك بسبب تجاهله
جميع الاجراءات الام نيه تقريبا اما في
الداخل الاوكراني فصرحت صحيفه تركيه ان
زيلنسكي يواجه انتقادات لاذعه بانه اصبح
فعلا شخصا غير مرغوب به في اوكرانيا
وبالاضافه الى ذلك فقد الرئيس شعبيته
السابقه على الساحه الدوليه وتتخلى
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
تدريجيا عن دعمهما لكيف هذا وافادت صحيفه
موسكوفسكي كومسوموليتس الروسيه بان السبيل
الوحيد لمنع اوكرانيا من الانهيار هو
تشجيع كيف على الت التفاوض مع روسيا وبحسب
الصحيفه ان هذه هي فكره لرئيس حلف النيتو
السابق راس موسن وهي تقنيه تلاعب قديمه
تسمى الباب الامامي حيث عليك ان تطلب شيئا
كبيرا لتصل في الاخير الى الشيء الذي
تريده في السياق ذاته افاد رئيس المخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه كيريل بودان اوف بان
موسكو وكيف يمكن ان لا توقعا معاهده سلام
حتى بعد انتهاء الاعمال القتاليه مشيرا
الى ان تسويه النزاعات القانونيه قد
يستغرق عقودا ميدانيا افادت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بان قواتها تقوم بعمليه هجوميه
بالقرب من ادي افكا وان القوات الاوكرانيه
تغير تكتيكها القتالي بسبب نقص الذخائر
مضيفه انها استهدفت مركز قياده لواء
الهجوم 79 المحمول جوا التابع للقوات
الاوكرانيه في جمهوريه الدونتس الشعبيه
لتعود الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن الحصيله بتكب
الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من
895 فردا بين قتيل وجريح واسقاط 23 مسيره
اوكرانيه واعتراض صاروخي هاي مارس
امريكيين وقنبله جويه موجهه جيدام خلال 24
[موسيقى]
ساعه